judging from the emails i've been
getting from many of you
um it sounds like much of my audience
agrees with me
that it feels as though american
democracy
is in peril it's a sort of precarious
state right now hanging on the brink
with the president openly saying
the election is rigged that the correct
result would be that
he wins and that if he doesn't win
preemptively he's saying it will have
been fraud
and he will not necessarily leave the
white house peacefully so
it's natural it's common it's logical
to be feeling despair and helplessness
right now donald trump and his cronies
have gotten away with everything
with so much and our old friend
john nichols at the nation wrote a
really great piece
about the bernie sanders toolkit for
defending
against donald trump's threats to
democracy bernie sanders actually spoke
at george washington university last
week
and went through what must happen
and i think this is useful both to
understand the nuts and bolts
but also just to have some hope some
hope so here are the ideas bernie's
plan to defend democracy number one
establish a nonpartisan commission to
oversee the election now the devil
is always in the details with these
nonpartisan commissions
uh but but that is the idea have by far
the largest voter turnout in american
history bernie and i
110 aligned on this i've been saying for
months now
whatever the reality is going to be
about voter suppression
whatever else the biggest ever turnout
is the starting point to trying to
remove donald trump
people should vote as early as possible
says bernie
absolutely the earlier you vote either
through in-person early voting
or vote by mail or hand delivering your
absentee ballot
the earlier the better all state
legislatures
must allow mail-in ballots to be counted
before election day this is key
32 states already allow this some don't
if we can get a jump on counting mail-in
ballots
we reduce the threat of the scenario
in which donald trump is slightly ahead
in some key states on election day
and uses lawyers to stop or slow down
the counting of as
yet uncounted absentee ballots the more
ballots that are counted early
the better off we are news media should
clarify
says bernie there is no longer a single
election day it's important that
media also explain to people you can
vote now in many states
early voting has started in many states
mail-in voting has started in many
states and that it is not just about
november
3rd anymore social media companies
must stop disinformation from being
spread on their platforms
we have a blockbuster story from channel
4
in the uk about donald trump's targeted
deterrence of black voters in 2016
and a big piece of that is social media
and it is also uh
uh on the social media companies to stop
disinformation
and there should be both congressional
in dc and state hearings in state
legislatures
to explain how the election will be
handled
in the event of all of these various
scenarios now not all of these ideas are
bernie's original ideas the nonpartisan
commission for example
was the idea of former director of now
national intelligence
dan coats the aclu has been putting
forth a lot of these ideas etc but the
point
is there are things to do now
not waiting until later if we wait we
lose
biden needs an army of lawyers ready to
go now not on november 4th
we learned last week that at least some
lawyers the dnc
and the the biden campaign have at the
ready those lawyers need to not just be
ostensibly ready the lawyers need to
know
now not later what are the different
strategies that donald trump's lawyers
might use to swing the election to him
the time is now not later we're at a
structural disadvantage
here if we are playing defense and they
are playing offense
they only need one strategy we haven't
thought of they might have six
strategies if we defend against
five they've got number six so there is
a difficulty implicit
in playing defense in this way but the
time is now to think about it not uh
not later so get your absentee ballot if
that's your plan you can go to vote.org
absentee hyphen ballot very important
vote.org forward slash absentee
hyphen that's the dash ballot you can
also just google vote.org absentee
ballot it'll be the first link that
comes up
and we are linking to that website in
the description to the youtube video i
tracked my ballot yesterday here in
massachusetts
it's currently pending it shows that my
primary ballot was of course received i
voted absentee in the primary
they haven't been sent out yet most
states have tracking systems
vote.org will tell you exactly how to
register in any state in which you live
very very important bernie has a plan
we need plans we need strategy we can't
wait until 11 pm on november 3rd
when the trump lawyers get ready to
petition courts to stop the counting of
absentee ballots
we wait until then we're done uh so
that's why it's so important to move
on this right now and uh there
we can all do something even if it's
just having a plan
that increases the likelihood of your
vote being tallied correctly that's a
plan that's something we can do
yes you can phone bank yes you can
volunteer to be a poll worker
so on and so forth one of our sponsors
is privacy.com they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plugin
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies
who you are you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft and
it's free there's no catch whatsoever
but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman